The Rise of Skywalker is filled with plot
twists and references that only older fans
will get — as well as some disturbing ideas
that only mature viewers will notice. Children
will enjoy the Skywalker Saga's finale just
fine, but will they pick up on these plot
points? We think not. Spoilers ahead.
So, let's talk about The Rise of Skywalker's
big secret. Rey is Palpatine's granddaughter.
Surprise? Eh, maybe not. Abrams has been hinting
that he undid The Last Jedi's "nobody" twist
for a while now, and leaks about Rey's true
heritage have been circulating on the internet
for months.
But if Palpatine has a granddaughter, that
means he has a kid. If you're old enough to
know the story of the birds and the bees,
you know that means old, wrinkly, yellow-eyed
Palpatine played a little ding dong ping pong
with some lucky lady. He's fully operational,
if you catch our drift.
“Ha.”
Unfortunately, The Rise of Skywalker doesn't
reveal the identity of Palpatine's lover or
his children, leaving the comics and novels
to explain those mysteries. That's too bad,
because we'd love to meet the woman who got
seduced by those shapeless black robes. We
bet she has some interesting stories to tell.
It took 11 movies, but there's finally a canonically
same-sex couple onscreen in a Star Wars movie.
No, it's not the sequel trilogy's most dynamic
couple, Finn and Poe Dameron. It's Commander
D'Acy, one of the top-ranking Resistance officers,
and her wife, a Resistance fighter named Wrobie
Tyce who lock lips while the Resistance is
celebrating the defeat of Palpatine.
Kids probably won't even notice the moment,
which is over almost as soon as it begins,
but adults will certainly realize what the
inclusion of a same-sex couple in a Star Wars
feature film means. Over the past four decades,
Star Wars has been remarkably conservative
when it comes to depicting relationships.
But most adults will also realize that it's
a very small step. Simply showing two women
kissing isn't real representation. D'Acy isn't
a real character in the film. We don't know
her hopes, dreams, motivations, or fears.
Heck, we barely even know what she sounds
like. D'Acy was a good start, but Disney and
Lucasfilm still have a long way to go.
Even if children are aware of Carrie Fisher's
passing, they're probably not going to give
too much thought to how Leia returns for The
Rise of Skywalker. There's too much else going
on. For those of us who grew up with Princess
Leia, however, it's almost impossible not
to think about Fisher's death in 2016 every
time her most famous creation shows up onscreen.
As such, adults are probably going to notice
all the tricks that J. J. Abrams and the Rise
of Skywalker crew used to give Leia the sendoff
she deserves. As promised, Abrams used outtakes
from The Force Awakens and The Last Jedi in
Leia's scenes, not a digital recreation. You
can tell. Leia's lines are noticeably vague.
It's up to her scene partners to deliver the
specifics.
Given the situation, it actually works pretty
well. Leia is the heart of this movie, and
it's wonderful to get a chance to say goodbye
but the sleight of hand is something most
adults will definitely notice.
C-3PO gets The Rise of Skywalker's best lines,
but one of the movie's funniest moments doesn't
have any words at all. It comes at the very
end of the movie. As everyone celebrates,
Poe Dameron sees his old friend Zorii Bliss.
They lock eyes. Poe gives Zorii an inviting
tilt of his head. Zorii shakes him off. Poe
looks disappointed. The audience bursts into
laughter.
The subtext should go right over kids' heads,
but every adult in the theater will realize
that Poe was asking Zorii if she wanted to
get busy. They'll also know that Zorii completely
shut him down. Oh well. There's no harm in
trying. Look, Poe just defeated an entire
fleet of Star Destroyers. He won the war.
Emotions are riding high. Who can blame him
for calling up an ex to blow off some steam?
Rey, Finn, and Poe's quest takes them to the
planet Pasaana, where a festival is taking
place. The party, C-3PO explains, is thrown
by the Pasaana's natives, the Aki-Aki, and
is held once every 42 years.
If you're one of the lucky young'uns who grew
up in an age when new Star Wars movies have
always been a thing, that number won't mean
anything to you. If you've been following
the Skywalker Saga since the very beginning,
you should know immediately how Abrams and
his co-writer, Chris Terrio, landed on 42.
Star Wars: Episode IV A New Hope came out
in 1977. Star Wars: Episode IX The Rise of
Skywalker came out in 2019. Guess how many
years apart that is.
"42."
Maybe that's a clue for the future, too. Disney
says that its next Star Wars film will debut
in 2022, so you might as well go ahead and
set aside some time in 2064 now. You'll certainly
want to see how the next saga ends.
The Rise of Skywalker reveals that before
he joined the Resistance, Poe Dameron used
to run spice. The way the other characters
react, it's not a good thing, but it doesn't
sound so bad. Who doesn't add a pinch of cumin
or paprika to their dishes while they cook?
Even in space, food should taste good.
Except that's not the kind of spice they're
talking about. Just from the language used,
as well as the precedent set by Frank Herbert's
Dune, mature members of the audience who don't
already know will quickly figure out that
in Star Wars "spice" is basically slang for
drugs.
"He who controls the spice controls the universe."
Poe Dameron wasn't helping people season their
meals. He was profiting off of other peoples'
addictions.
In the Star Wars universe, the drug trade
is just as vicious and exploitative as it
is in real life. It's not a good thing for
someone like Poe to be involved in. Of course,
in his prime, the renowned scoundrel Han Solo
was known to smuggle spice, too. No wonder
Leia likes him.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
Star Wars stuff are coming soon. Subscribe
to our YouTube channel and hit the bell so
you don't miss a single one.